[Music]
oh where is my son
I better take good care of him I can't
find him where is my child
[Music]
Timmy baby baby we talked about this
Timmy I said it no come back you have a
drug problem Timmy I know what happened
bro you vanished
what are you well Timmy became a dildo
[Music]
how do I explain this to mom
all right good now you're not that good
night Timmy I love you even though
you're damn it oh my god
oh don't close the door on me young man
toilet oh my god wait wait wait look at
me wait turn around why me and turn out
hi oh my god it looked like your neck is
completely broken like it oh my god
please don't you Timmy no no no no just
a mirror behind you Oh Oh God
we look we're such a dysfunctional
family I'm sorry I'm sorry to me you
need to take a poop oh my god
never again never again yo Jimmy good
one good one you did it super strong
baby that's my boy go hey and now you're
gonna drown [__] Oh
open your mouth Jimmy
[Music]
what are you doing come out of there
where'd you [__] yeah you find my
sleeping baby you're a terrible father
you use baby key on the dad daddy way
wins yeah that's right Timmy [__] come
on I like my bald bald patch on my yeah
rematch
I guess oh [__] yeah does it actually
work
Hey Oh daddy where are you
[Laughter]
oh my god I'm super fast daddy will
never find me daddy please ain't no baby
am I gonna electrocute himself okay wait
see if you can find me I'm in the room
where were you saw me last I am in this
very specific location what the [__] the
pictures moving is that you ghost baby
no that's not me but alright it's
getting close no I don't know I'm stuck
hey don't call me a little [__] hey
daddy pick me at bite 97 can catch me
[__] can't catch Oh God gotta go faster
hey English no let me live my life daddy
I'm gonna kill myself dad I know you are
don't come find you [__] oh really I
got you right here where are you I see
you Danny
oh come here
never fun baby what the [__] is wrong
with freaky baby [__] ooh what is this
soap Oh food it tastes so good oh it
tastes so good yeah me come here play a
song with daddy daddy I'm gonna kill you
[__] up daddy sit down help all your
health is dropping that's right
alright fix this Jenna
don't die Oh electrical socket that is
its circuits oh my god you board
everything yes please you forgot a
blocked hey daddy how could happen to me
eat the salmon man mrs. Tabak no you're
dead
[Music]
I got it going don't don't come any
further Oh daddy
right there job drop the gun okay okay
let's just talk this out
no daddy but luckily I will change your
diaper
oh but if mommy comes back I'm not
drinking chocolate milk for dinner do
you get as much jacket mix yourself to
me oh my god my channel is a demon baby
honey
okay honey have a good life I think
you're ready I trained you well son oh
my God my face it's [__] hey come here
what I want you to go into and take a
poopa it's time for you to Papa okay you
gonna potty-trained me daddy little
Jackie boy going going go and take a
[__] God ah there's only one way to kill
a demon baby and it's to drown it in the
toilet oh what's over here
is it the baby restrain II I grabbed a
baby Oh give me no please please steady
I don't I don't know tell you okay come
here baby
daddy please daddy how could you say no
to this face oh yes I can
oh this works now tell mommy I got [__]
on your pillow what the [__] Jimmy
you're out of control
God [__] it hurts it's gonna spank you
baby
Oh shame on you shame appropriate it's
not a it's not what you think it is it's
a baby toy no I can stay in there and
think about what you did daddy's got
some whisky to drink dad you you got an
alcoholic problem I know you're Irish
man in house but I can't do it baby
wait you should have cried [__] look
like you broke your legs
oh wait wait okay okay hey take two
music see how nailed it you did whatever
this is
good work on my end I have to watch your
video to see okay I'm sure he looks cool
I'm sure look super cool oh mama baby
really pissed now rematch so mad when I
come okay